[Music]
well good morning
everyone thanks for coming out on this
cold and snowy weekend maybe that's the
reason you came out to get away from the
cold and snow
right so uh how many students do we have
from New Haven
today all right great West Haven
how about some any from
Hampton yay hamton that's where I'm from
Guilford how about
Massachusetts anyone make it from
massach or New York anyone from out of
state this week no out of Staters
everyone's from Connecticut this week
well thanks again for showing up for uh
for the start of science Saturday for
the spring semester um I'm glad you
could all come out today we got a real
treat uh uh
friend of mine Professor Mark Reed uh is
going to to tell us about his research
today um there's a we have an office uh
of institutional research on campus that
studies everything one of the things
they study is where faculty come from
and so I have what what my uh postdoc
adviser told me is the mut pedigree uh I
did my bachelor's degree and my PhD at
the same place and then I worked in
Industry pretty much at the same place
and uh
uh and and then eventually made my way
to Yale and the guys at or said Kurt
you're very unusual I mean there's only
one other one like you and when I was
looking up his CV today I found out that
this is the other one like me so
Professor Reed did his uh bachelor's and
PhD at at Syracuse uh the orange men the
the other the other team that Yukon
plays I guess right I always root
against the uh Yukon I wrote for the
orange
one uh and and then uh he did something
that used to be a lot more common uh and
and I think is has probably had had a
big effect on his career he worked in
Industry that doesn't happen so often
anymore um but it really I think for me
it helped ground me in what I do and I
have certain it it it it has helped him
uh make his research more responsive uh
to society and after that somehow we uh
got him to come to Yale where he's been
a force of nature uh ever since and I'm
a physical chemist uh and so I don't
over LA with too many of the electrical
engineers except when I need some help
with uh with designing instrumentation
in my lab but uh Professor Reed uh has
got this dream of making Electronics out
of molecules uh and uh and that's that's
happening uh you've got your organic LED
displays that's sort of the first wave
of this in consumer products and it's
it's it's really going to be a
revolution and he's sort of the father
of this right so uh join me today and uh
welcoming Professor
ree well thank you thank you very much
can you hear me good all right so um it
is a true pleasure to uh give this
science Saturday talk because the reason
I'm a scientist was when I was about 12
years old I went to a science Saturday
at Syracuse
University and it turned me on
and it really showed me and so I went to
the first one I loved it and I kept
going to them and uh learned uh the fact
that science is just not what you read
in the textbooks but it's a really
vibrant profession and uh just
tremendously interesting so um after I
um uh I stuck around Syracuse and I went
to uh to school there I got my
undergraduate and graduate degree there
and then I went to Texas Instruments and
um started to wear cowboy
boots and um worked in uh the same
Laboratories that Jack kby made the
first integrated circuit and then uh
eventually came up here to to Yale um I
I'm in the electrical engineering
department but I'm actually a physicist
the reason I'm in electrical engineering
is uh electrical engineering pays
more uh but seriously the the area of
what of what I do which is electronics
uh spans everything from chemistry to
electrical engineering to physics and a
lot of other disciplines it's a big wide
discipline electrical engineering is the
biggest uh uh profession in the world
there are more people in electrical
engineering than any other
profession so then I came here to Yale
and I started to make tiny
things and uh this scale bar that you
see right there is a
micrometer and you kind of till you
don't have a good feeling for how big
that is so let me give you an idea of
the size scale here take a hair from
your
head and look at how big it is and it's
about 80 micrometers
across so these little things and here's
a little bit of corporate graffiti that
I did here um is uh at a size scale
that's pretty hard to imagine and in
fact modern transistors are about as big
as the period at the end of that
sentence so I'm going to tell you a
little bit about electronics and where
it's headed and some of the fun things
uh when do you think the first computer
was actually made
anybody 1940s 1950s yeah what do you
think 1967
1967 yeah in fact there are a lot of
computers made over the age
here is the first
computer and it was
mechanical guy done by a guy by the name
of babage uh he here's a part from his
first computer that he made uh didn't
wasn't very smart didn't do a whole lot
of things in fact it didn't work very
well at all because at the time they
couldn't machine things very very
accurately well in fact a number of
years ago uh people tried to uh
reconstruct it from his d from his
original diagrams and it sits in um uh
the uh College of or Museum of London I
believe and it's a mechanical computer
and it works with gears and switches and
things like that and they actually do
computations um and in fact it
works but it's a big thing that whole
computer would fill up this entire room
and would only be able to do a few
things this is it's actually a wonderful
thing there's a nice divide that's what
it looks like when it does it so check
it out if you're interested it's a
really neat uh neat
system
okay but then we wanted to start to get
electronic so in fact the first
transistor or a transistor type thing
was actually invented here at Yale by a
guy by the name of Lee Deforest and it's
something called a vacuum tube and it
was a vacuum tube transistor it's a very
interesting story in fact uh
this guy he was an undergraduate here he
was playing around in the laboratory he
actually got kicked out of Yale because
he short circuited the entire campus and
blacked everything
out well they they admitted him back a
few weeks later and he went on to become
very famous and uh really was able to uh
uh to move the field forward and being
able to use things that would look like
a
transistor and so a few years later
people are actually able to make
computers out of this this is the first
computer ever made that was
electronic and it was something called
the
eniac and here's a picture of a part of
the thing and in fact it roughly was the
size of this
room and it was it could do all of 5,000
additions or subtractions per
second or 30 multiplications or 50
divisions per second you can buy a
calculator in the checkout line of a
grocery store that's a factor of 10 more
powerful than this thing for $1
today actually was was most impressive
to do this it uh had to use 18,000
vacuum tubes here's a little picture of
a vacuum tube if you've not ever seen
one um and probably most impressive is
that its electric bill was $1,800 per
month and that's in 1946
$6 when they turn this was in um uh
Philadelphia when they turned this thing
on Philadelphia dimmed a little
bit so in fact what's most impressive a
vacuum tube is like a light bulb it it
actually glows you ever seen one who's
ever seen a vacuum tube and if if for
for chance if you ever get a an old TV
set and look inside it then you'll see
these vacuum tubes and like little light
bulbs what happens if you take a light
bulb and go on to the middle of a forest
at night what
happens all the Flies and bugs all
collect around to it in fact this thing
one of its failure modes was the fact
that it would attract Ms and flies and
they would crawl in that short circuit
out the thing in fact this is the first
bug in a
computer it was a real
bug okay so to run this thing I mean
they were able to actually do kind
amputations for the first time that NE
people never
could um but it wasn't very good and so
things really changed when people
realized that maybe we can make these
things smaller and so here was the real
first transistor made in
1947 uh down the road at Bell
Laboratories uh and by the next year
after the demonstration they're actually
selling these things uh they made about
a thousand of these things called type A
transistors by the way if you ever run
across that snap it up because it's a
huge collector's
item and by 1954 they were making
millions of these things so they were
able to actually make transistors that
would eventually enable what we have
benefited from the information
technology now a modern computer chip
that runs your computer or runs your
cell phone or runs your iPad has roughly
a trillion transistors on it
for people familiar with it 10 to the
9th using exponential notation so a
trillion
transistors now suppose I had a bucket
of these things sitting here okay so I
got a bucket of transistors over here
and I'm going to wire them up over
here and I'm going to wire up a trillion
transistors and so I take a transistor
and I place it on my little breadboard
one every
second 24 hours a
day 7 days a week 365 days a year how
long would it take me to make the
equivalent of one of our integrated
circuits well there's to do the
calculation there's roughly Pi * 10 the
7 seconds in a year so it would take you
years to make
one and you can buy one of these little
things for a few tens of dollars and
they're all over over the world so it's
an amazing new technology and that
happened because of something called
that again jack Kilby who invented the
concept of the integrated circuit as
well as another guy by the name of
Robert noise came up with the idea that
you can put a lot of things made
together all at the same time and it was
an important intellectual
concept so the concept is that you
actually
use a pattern that you've generated a
mask that creates
patterns on an integrated on a piece of
silicon but here's the important thing
instead of taking one at a time and
putting them on a red board on your
integrated circuit it makes two at the
same time or 10 at the same time or a
thousand at the same time or a trillion
at the same time so instead of doing
doing the sequential process of doing
things like the uh Ford assembly line in
fact it's a what's called a parallel
process and that concept was so
important it enabled the generation of
integrated circuits that we have
today so shortly after the the idea of
this concept came in they here is one of
the first integrated circuits
made and done by
Intel and and it had um it had all of
what are called four bits of information
and if you know anything about modern
computer that's absolutely
nothing and it only had 2,300
transistors and it ran at a blazing
110 kilohertz we now do
gigahertz and it cost about in uh $910
cost about
$500 but in fact it was one of the first
integrated circuits few years later
they've increased it they've increased
this about a factor of
10 um they've increased the speed
dramatically and it costs roughly the
same today incredible increase in the
information density incredible increase
in the number of transistors that you
can make and it costs roughly the same
so that has been the March and what's
called the Silicon Steamroller as we're
able to make more and more complex
things for roughly the same
cost okay so here's a pretty picture of
what we do today very complicated
integrated circuits but it's actually
not all that complicated in fact one of
the big secrets that the electrical
engineers keep and don't tell anybody is
it's
simple so we just we just don't tell
people that and it's it's actually very
easy to understand how these things all
get connected together so it's a very
Wonder wonderful interesting technology
and pretty simple
technology and this increase is
something called Mo's
law and what it says is that the number
of integrated the number of transistors
that we can put on one of these
integrated
circuits doubles every two
years now just think about what they
mean doubling it doesn't mean that it
increases by a factor of two it doubles
over what it was before
so 1 2 4
16 etc etc and so the number is
increased dramatically and so now this
is kind of an old graph uh uh it's
continuing on to that and we have
billions and billions of transistors
that we can put on these and so that's
why the things we have are getting more
and more complex can do wonderful things
some of the uh for example uh who saw
the the latest Star Wars
right and you know a good 80% of that
movie was computer
generated and so all the scenes and you
couldn't do that many years ago and so a
lot of the things that we see around us
today are due to the wonderful ability
to be able to do computations at a
blazing
speed
okay now a lot of things follow follow
Moore's Law here's another thing that
follows Moore's Law the number of
chickens
so uh but that's something called an
experience curve for that it's it's due
to Something in economics so
okay so we're able to make these tiny
tiny little
transistors very very small in fact here
is the size here's a typical transistor
that we make these days it's only 45
nanometers now remember I said a
micron that's a th000
nanometers and now it's that big
so it's tremendously
small okay so we can make things really
really tiny and that's what we do in our
Laboratories today is try to shrink
transistors and make them really really
tiny so the question is if we go back to
Mo's law back here how much further is
that going to go is that going to go on
forever our computer is going to start
to get better and better and better all
the
time and here something that's really
fascinating and you should take take
attention to electronics is going to
change dramatically within your
lifetime and it has to and I'm going to
show you why because this is not going
to continue
forever it's actually going to
stop and when that
happens a lot of people are going to go
what do we do next what's the next
possible thing that we can do
electronics and that's what I'm going to
talk about today some of the wild and
wonderful things that we think we can do
so so why is it stopping is it because
we can can't make the thing smaller and
smaller and smaller and so that's what I
do part of my research on is how small
can I make these things so here's a
little plot that shows the size of the
transistors that we make and back when
more guessed that things were going to
double every time we're about this
size uh by about a decade ago we were
down to here uh we are now approximately
right here and and we're starting to get
incredibly
small so we can make things incredibly
small in fact I can make things down to
a single
atom we've been able to measure the
properties of a single atom in our
laboratory so in fact how small can we
go uh in fact no let me go to to this in
our Laboratories we actually made a
transistor out of a single
molecule so how tiny is that how tiny is
that that's that's less than a nanometer
in size
and it
worked now took a lot of work to be able
to get it that
tiny but nonetheless that was an
important lesson in the fact that size
doesn't matter anymore we can make
things incredibly
small so is that going to be the limit
of electronics so it's an important
question from both an intellectual
standpoint and from a industrial
standpoint from an intellectual
standpoint is what is the limits
of making a device and what are the
properties that determine that and from
an industrial standpoint they want to
know if they can do the next thing so
they can invest in the capabilities and
the machines to be able to do that and
it's a big
investment so to make a modern Intel
clean room to do the modern chips that I
was talking about that I showed you some
pictures of how much do you think that
costs you know maybe a million dollars
right
$5 billion dollar to make a single
fabrication facility to make
state-of-the-art things so it's a
serious investment from a company
standpoint okay so we can make things
really small so we took a little
molecule does anyone recognize what that
is Benzene it's Benzene it's a single
molecule of
benzene and sandwich between two
contacts and we were able to actually
show it was a transistor and so for some
of the people that that's actually the
transistor curves we got don't worry
about that but it actually shows that it
works like a transistor it actually show
like the same worked like the same types
of transistors that Bell Labs the same
type of vacuum tube properties that lead
to forested and it was made out of a
single
molecule so size doesn't matter
anymore it's how hot you
are that's the real limit of electronics
and it wasn't obvious until about seven
eight years ago that people really
realized that this was the limit of
electronics so if we go back to some of
the uh first serious uh
microprocessors in fact my first
computer was a something that ran on
something called a I uh Intel 386
computer and so that gave off a certain
amount of power appears in some units
and I'll show you exactly what that
means in a second
and this is as we March down in size and
pack more and more transistors onto an
integrated
circuit and a few years ago we were
working with things called pentiums and
that was roughly the temperature of a
hot
plate okay so what did we do we made
more transistors on an integrated
circuit and we packed more and more on
and now we're at a Pentium 4 and there's
a nuclear
reactor
and there's a rocket
nozzle and that's the surface of the
Sun so in fact it became something that
people started to recognize is going to
be the limit of electronics is that the
more transistors you put onto a
integrated circuit the more each one
gives off a little bit of heat when it
does its
computation and the more energy it's
going to give off and power it's going
to give off and this little nuclear
reactor point there is is a very
important point because the nuclear
reactors are built on roughly the limit
of what materials can handle most
materials above that kind of heat will
start to degrade and fall apart so we
don't know how to how to do that
now this is affecting you
today you might not know it but for the
last seven or eight years your computers
have not increased in
performance what they've done is they've
done clever tricks that you haven't seen
to be able to make it look like it's
performing
better uh let me go to this okay now
complicated graph here but the important
thing to notice is and here's a very
simple way to look at it this is the
number of transistors the green plot
that's increasing so as Time Marches On
the number of Compu computers or follow
a number of transistors on a chip are
following Mo's law and so we're ping
more and more and more on them that's
good this thing right here which says
the clock speed has
stopped and it's
flattened and that goes against being
able to increase the
performance because if I put more
transistors on an integrated circuit I
want to clock them FAS faster to get the
increase in performance but if I have
more transistors on there and I haven't
increased how fast they do the
computations well I've lost the game
there so that's what people are dealing
with today and I'll show you some of the
interesting workarounds that some people
are thinking about so in fact here is
over the years that's a log scale within
the last starting about 2008 to 2014 and
there's different designs so that's why
there are different numbers there but
you can see it pretty much is flattened
off so people are starting to come up
with wild ideas to be able to do this
here's the wildest idea I've ever seen
is they actually take the thing and they
plunge it into water to be able to cool
the thing
down that actually might
happen and people are coming up with
interesting ideas to be able to get
around
that okay so as people are trying to
come up with better ways to be able to
increase the performance of that a whole
lot of new ideas have come
up and you're going to see a lot of this
in the next few
years now the interesting thing is that
energy this the the fact that these
things heat up is not just a problem for
the computer it's a problem for
society in fact right now just searches
internet searches uses 3% % of all the
global energy that we have and it's
increasing and I suspect within a year
or two it'll be up to 5% and it'll
continue to increase so we got to come
up with something because that really
translates into greenhouse gases and all
the problems we know about uh energy
production
so here is a wonderful little
complicated graph that you don't really
need to understand of but you just need
to look at some of the names that we
have right here what this is is how fast
the thing is how small it is how much it
costs and the energy that it gives off
and there's all sorts of different types
of things that people are trying to
think of that are able to get around
this problem for example you see this
right thing blue means you've gotten
around that there are things like
biologically inspired computation there
is molecular computation the molecule
devices that I was showing you right
there and these things might have much
lower power dissipation than what we
have right here there's something called
nms I'm going to show you a few examples
of these where people are starting to do
this and it's a wonderfully vibrant
research area so if I had to pick a
topic in a a field of science that had
the most incredible ideas and diversity
of things it's the electronics trying to
figure out what it's going to do next so
it's a wonderful thing to think
about
okay so what do we what are some of
these things that we have right here
well a lot of these are enabled by the
fact that within the last 10 years
scientists have been able to have
started to get into a field called
nanotechnology that allows us to make
things at amazingly small scales things
that are almost
inconceivable um here's just an example
to show you these size scales here's a
typical type of integrated circuit that
kind of gives you an idea of the size
scale of what these are with respect to
something like a little ant that's
sitting here that's actually a little
integrated circuit I made in my
laboratory and a friend of mine was a
microscopist so I said can you put it in
his mouth and he did okay but we've been
able to do things like be able to play
single atoms one at a time in various
places here's one of the first
experiments it spells out can can you
read it
IBM right done by a guy who did some of
the first experiments on showing that
you can actually do single atom
manipulation with
things this one's kind of interesting
because this is in kanji it spells out
atom
so and we can make mechanical things too
here's a tiny little
guitar made up the up the road at a
place called Cornell nanofabrication
facility and you can see it's it's it's
a nice little Fender guitar you can see
the actual strings that it has right
there it actually plays notes it does it
does except there are gigahertz
frequencies you can't hear them but in
fact we actually have a guy down the
down the road Hong Tang who actually
makes things like this and is able to
sense the various types of vibrations
that happen in very small systems like
that so there's all sorts of interesting
new technologies that are happening in
fact one of the newest techn or one of
the uh oldest Technologies in the world
of being able to do this has been
revived and it's something that are
called Quantum
dots now in fact these things right here
have all sorts of applications and
they're in your life today and you don't
even know
it who's seen some of the uh the uh
who's ever bought one of these new LED
light bulbs right those some of those
have Quantum dots in it that make them
more
efficient so um these are used for all
sorts of medical purposes here's an
example of a little rat that has a
little tumor there and you're actually
able to image the tumor using these
things called Quantum dots and what they
are is tiny little Assemblies of just
tiny little packets of atoms very very
very very tiny actually there's an
interesting thing it was actually
invented back in 184 uh
1480 although they didn't know it in
fact all these beautiful colored glasses
that were invented around on that in
that time frame how did they do that
people would take glass uh that was
perfectly clear and then they'd add a
little bit of gold or they'd add a
little bit of copper and if they cooled
it just right then it would have in fact
this thing that you see right here which
is called Rose glass is when you take
gold and you would add it and to The
Melting glass and then cool it down at a
certain rate in fact you did if you
didn't cool it down at a certain rate it
would turn into something that looked
like
mud but if you did just right it turned
out to have this beautiful color they
didn't know why actually what they were
doing is they were creating these little
Quantum dots in the glass and it gave it
this nice color and the various types of
colors that you see right here so it's a
wonderful little new technology
reinvented now to be able to do all
sorts of interesting
things so all these new materials and
all these new fabrication processes that
people have been exploring for the last
few years has opened up all sorts of new
opportun
unities one of the most interesting
things is something called mems micro
electr mechanical systems to make things
like gears and motors on a very very
tiny length scale so here's a little
rotating gear 50 microns that's about
the size of again a human
hair um here's a little thing that does
some Optics here's a little switch here
here is a uh um something by a group at
Sandia that makes little rotating
machines for various applications and
I'll show you an example of one of this
here's a little movie I'm going to show
you that has one of these little
rotating gears and it's got a little bug
on
it and so he's getting a little
ride but it shows you and the reason I
do this is that little ratchet gear
right there if you've ever looked at an
Old Clock an old mechanical clock which
has a little piston that goes back and
forth something called a ratchet
this actually is ratcheting at
incredibly high speeds so that they can
precisely determine and move this thing
to with uh tremendous interesting things
now one of the interesting things is
that when you're on a very small size
scale your intuition kind of violates or
your your intuition doesn't really tell
you what's going on here's a little bug
at a very high
speed he's able to grab onto thing he's
getting a real
ride actually one of the very
interesting things when things get down
to a very small size scale Things become
very sticky so he doesn't have any
trouble hanging on to the thing you
would because you're so big in fact
that's why things like geckos and flies
can climb walls because their surfaces
are very small and you get sticky
things okay so this whole area of
microelectr mechanical systems are in
fact not just doing gears and Motors but
people are thinking back can I make
something like the Babbage machine out
of things that are very very tiny can I
do mechanical computation and does that
help me being able to solve this energy
problem and so that's a very big active
area of research that people all all
around the world are thinking about
these
days
in fact some of the really interesting
things that people are doing and a huge
big area of research is trying to blend
biology with
electronics now who's who's had a class
and and heard about DNA right and you
know that DNA sticks together because
these base pairs that you have on the
different sides right so when you line
up DNA then you have that that one of
these nucleic acids binds to the other
nucleic acid but not the other ones and
so when DNA forms it is a binding to T
and C binding to G etc etc and so that's
what
forms
DNA now here's an example where someone
came up with an idea and there a guy by
the name of uh Ned Seaman is he said
forget about biology as far as
life because I can get things a bind on
a very small length scale preferentially
can I make things mechanical out of
them so what he did is he said okay I'm
going to take uh DNA and I'm going to
make it fold back and forth and back and
forth and back and forth like that
because I can design in the rules to be
able to make it do
that and so that should be like a little
sheet of paper and in fact that's what
it looks like he made a tiny little
sheet of DNA paper there it's a little
bit wrinkled
so he showing the fact it wasn't so
stable but in fact he
could um but I can make more than sheets
of paper I can actually design in all
sorts of patterns that I want to be able
to do interesting things so here's
another
example he made a little star out of
it by being able to program in all the
various types of binding things to be
able to do that beautiful little
star and how big is this thing this
thing that little scale bar that you see
there that's about 10
microns so very small this one I love
right
there and uh it's really interest so
here's a whole group of them it's not
totally perfect you know you can see
some of them that one is pretty good but
this one is likey screaming you
know but it's a really new interesting
technology that we think that about and
so in fact a lot of people around the
world are looking at this as a possible
way to be able to inte to fabricate
integrated circuits in fact on a much
smaller size or excuse me uh much less
expensive and wouldn't have to use all
those billion dollar fabrication
facilities
okay there's a map of the
world shrunk down to something that is
about 20 microns across
so it's really phenomenal stuff so it's
called DNA
origami okay
yes what DNA where did you get the DNA
ah so where' you get the DNA um actually
for uh how Pap make DNA is what they'll
do is they will take one of the um uh
base pairs or just imagine you had a
little string of DNA and I want to add
something to the end so what they do is
they put a little group on the end where
preferentially one is going to come in
and substitute and then the other one
goes away and that one has another
preferential and it comes in a
substitute sub so you can make a string
of DNA with a programmed sequence and in
fact you don't need a laboratory to do
it you can go out and you can order it
on the
web and it'll cost you about $50 or so
with a tiny little vial like this and
it'll come back and you'll have
precisely that program sequence that you
want because there are many companies
that do this for a living and they do
things like Gene sequencing and various
types of things for biomedical
applications but this isn't biomedical
it's actually structural but it uses the
same type of
thing okay
now there's a lot of different stuff
going on in electronics these days and
let me just give you one example of the
way Electronics affects your
life and there's a whole area of what's
called three five materials not silicon
but other types of materials that people
do for what are called opto electronic
and radio frequency
applications an example is this thing
which is a laser it's precisely what I'm
pointing around right there this little
thing right here is a result of the
research over the last 20 years to be
able to not just have a laser pointer
but this is used for
telecommunications so the fact that you
can have such high speeds are due to the
fact that lasers are going over fiber
optics to be able to do
high-speed uh uh information but it's
does things like very efficient solar
cells um solar power people talk about
today uh and it's an ongoing debate and
people are trying to see if it's going
to be cost effective but in fact these
things right here are incredibly high
performance things solar cells made out
of these new materials in fact the
typical solar cell has an efficiency of
approximately 17 to 18% made out of
that's the one that you can buy that you
put onto your
roof this one is about
50% now it costs about a billion
dollars but up in space you really need
that so there are certain applications
where that efficiency is very
important uh modern radar systems here's
a picture of a modern radar system use
these different types of materials to do
that anytime you look at uh Intellicast
or what ever your favorite weather app
is then the radar maps that you see
there the storms moving through are due
to the fact that we have such incredibly
efficient radar systems these
days if you have a cell phone you have
one of these
things and in fact the ability of being
able to make these very fast radio
frequency transistors relatively cheaply
these days allows the enable the entire
cellular communication system that we
have
but the these are examples of the
various types of things but the one I
want to concentrate is on
this which is displays and
lighting and it's actually had a
tremendous
impact
so we're all familiar with light
emitting diodes if you have you know uh
you know a little camcorder or something
like that you see flashing red light
bulbs or flashing green LEDs if you
combine red green and blue and this is
the amazing thing that happened within
the last decade is people were able to
get the color blue in fact a a group of
people won the Nobel Prize a number of
years ago being able to actually create
blue light it combined red green blue
and what do you get you get
white now big deal I've just done
something a little bit differently to be
able to get white light well the point
is that it's amazingly efficient
efficient
so these light bulbs right here how
efficient are they as producing light
that comes down to US versus the power
that we put in well this one right here
which they should get rid of is an
incadescent light bulb and well there
are some incadescent oh yeah that's
right that's a that's an LED yeah you
actually did replace them
excellent the uh the lights that you
have at home the old style lights that
give off the Warm Glow those are called
incadescent light bulbs and they have an
efficiency of a approximately
10% in fact the warm you know there are
some they say this has a much warmer
glow to the thing it's actually those
are worse that's about 8% efficient
right the lights that are probably
behind those which are probably
florescent lights are on the order of 15
to 177% efficient
okay so that's better that's why people
do put in fluorescent light bulbs and
there are some that are called high
power florescent light bulbs that get up
to about 20 to
22% these things have an internal
efficiency of
99.9999% amazing in fact it turns out as
a really interesting Optical uh problem
is that the efficiency for light out is
actually trying to get the light out of
the thing in fact it's like a diamond in
Reverse you can't get the light out fast
enough to be able to bounces around
inside and people are working on that so
they've gotten up to about 55 to 60%
efficiency on these
things these things right
here have here is the their efficiency
as a function of year is here's the best
LED which has beat out all these other
thing like fluorescents and halogens and
high pressure sodium and all these kind
of
things so right now the best LEDs that
you can buy on the market are roughly
the same as the high pressure um uh
fluorescence which are on the order of
about 22% or so however the LEDs are
getting better and better and better and
this year they've just crossed over and
within the next five years they're going
to get up to about 30 to 35% and
hopefully we'll get all the way up to
50% or so in fact these the reason that
these work actually better and more
efficient is because of these Quantum
dots that I told you before that's
billions of barrels of oil that you've
saved so in fact this tiny little
electronic innovation has affected
worldwide Global energy dramatically so
the lesson is I know they're expensive
but buy the LED
lights they really save the world and
they actually save cost to you in the
end because they Lo last a very very
long
time okay um just I'm sorry that little
graph right there there's a little
figure that you might not have ever
thought about how much energy in the
world do we actually use for lighting
and in fact that's
30% of electricity is actually lo used
for lighting things that's a lot that's
a tremendous amount so and increasing
this efficiency is a very important
thing if you look at all the energy that
the United States uses and here's all
these various numbers of where it comes
from where it goes the only number
that's really important there is that's
the amount of electrical energy that is
lost 30% of our electrical energy is
lost due to the fact that we have
inefficient lighting and various types
of things so we are going to
dramatically change that with
this
okay now let's come back to to some of
the other IDE ideas that people are
thinking about there's a big area of
research in fact Yale is one of the
leaders in it you doing what's called
Quantum computation now what is quantum
computation transistor or transistors
that we know use bits of information a
one and a
zero Quantum computation uses things
that are not a one not a zero it's
somewhere in between and the way these
things actually do computation is using
quantum
mechanics and it's a very very very
researchy thing this is the biggest
quantum computer that people have ever
made 1 2 3 4 5 6 seven eight bits of
information but people are doing
experiments on that now and so over the
next few years you're going to start to
see a lot of interesting news articles
on being able to do more and more
efficient quantum computers why is that
important it uses a whole lot less
energy and so that potentially is an
idea that people have to get around the
energy problem of qu of
computation
um and being able to do these Quantum
type things you can actually see Quantum
effects these little fringes and ripples
and stuff like that are due to the
quantum effects that you see in when you
make one of these little structures
things that are call wave functions so
someday down the road you actually might
get into a class and read something on
quantum mechanics and the fascinating
thing is that today we actually play
around with quantum mechanics we design
things with quantum
mechanics however here's what I think
the future computation
is which is different from those other
people so not not that the other people
are wrong they have their ideas they're
exploring that but I actually think the
blend of biological systems with
electronics is going to be the one of
the most important things that's going
to happen over the next few
years and the reason I think about that
is IT addresses the underlying
fundamental problem of
energy now what are we doing today all
do we have things that blend Electronics
with biological do we have a cyborg do
we have a terminator and things like
that no we're far far away from that in
fact some of the first things that we're
doing right here is just making
electronic systems that can sense what's
going on in the world around
us and in fact this is a research that I
do in my laboratory I make little
systems like like this that has an
integrated circuit underneath it to be
able to sense things that exist in the
world around it in fact this was an
example of sensing a certain type of
molecule that is indicative of breast
cancer and I can do this at incredibly
small sensitive
levels and I can measure who is so who's
had a chemistry
class who knows what a mol or con
concentration is right so what happens
if you take something and a certain
number of atoms and I put it into a
liquid then I have a certain
concentration if I take one mole I put
it into one later that's called a mole
or a molar
concentration the bottom even if you
haven't had the CH chemistry class is
the smaller the concentration the more
the less molecules there
are so a for example
if I go and I do a test using uh
something you can buy in the store that
is to measure the amount of insulin and
and glucose you have in your system then
you can measure that at roughly
micromolar
concentrations our new systems like this
can measure it at
fomar
concentrations incredibly small
concentrations and I'll give you an
example of how small that
is a th bigger is what's called a pamic
concentration if I would take a grain of
salt and I would put it into an Olympic
swimming
pool that's a peamar
concentration and we can measure less
than that so these are the kind of
amazing sensitivities that we can get
out of these things so this kind of
research is just beginning for us to
sense the world around us eventually
we're going to make Electronics out of
this um but the reason that we're
thinking about
biology is a potential way to get around
the energy problem is the
following the whole last century of
making integrated circuits was using
wires that connects those all
together copper wires that connects one
transistor to another transistor to
another transistor and that's what
causes this heat
problem but there's an existence proof
on how to do it
better okay so here's what we make today
we have a billion trans
transistors operates a very high
speed that's about 100 watts and each of
these tiny transistors is about 30
net the existence proof that we can do
it better is
this
right it's got 10 to the 14th synapses
it's got a whole lot more so why doesn't
your head burn
up it only operates at about 20
watts for most
people
but actually this is like the picture I
showed you before it's immers in
liquid so in fact the important thing is
that
you
evolved constrained by low
power right you're a low power
system because if you're a higher power
you'd have to eat more food and you
wouldn't
survive so in fact you evolved to do
computation at low power that was your
conr constraint we didn't have this
constraint for that we just put the
pedal to the metal and did it as fast as
we could but then all of a sudden we've
realize the problem that we have with
that so we're going to start to make
things that look more like this and
we're starting to do the basis of of the
research to be able to do that are you
going to see a brain like this within
your lifetime probably not but you're
going to see the beginnings of the
research to be able to do
that and it's very important because it
does computation a much different way
and let me give you an example so you're
here at Yale in a classroom I get to
give you a test okay now if you UND if
you know the answer to the test don't
yell it out okay just raise your hand or
something like that okay I'm going to
show you a little
picture I'll come back to that there's a
little
picture now a computer recognize this
within about 10
milliseconds
okay you haven't recognized it
yet okay let me show you a little
more
okay took about 100
milliseconds almost a second for the
computer to realize recognize
this okay
now see how long it takes it how fast it
takes you to do
this a computer is still working on it
it'll take about a
minute because it does computation in a
much different
way so being able to not only do low
power computation and computation in the
different way the brains operate from
the way that we've done transistors is
what the future of electronics is to
figure out the difference between here
so that we can get around this problem
problem of energy uh energy
consumption thank you very
[Applause]
much I'm sure Professor would be Happ
question I I've got one your last
example that's really pretty cool
thinking that the human brain is going
to do better
so it's not just doing in biology though
right so you instead of having that many
more transistors it just had a hell of a
lot more interconnect so if anyone tried
to engineer and make the hell of a lot
more interconnects with slower uh
devices to simulate a brain and see if
you actually can you know get go down
that path right yes they have so the way
that we think about modern electron
is that we connect one transistor to
another transistor to another transistor
kind of like a switching
Network now what we do is we have one
input one output one input one maybe two
in two inputs one output two inputs one
output two inputs one output that's the
way we put transistors together and
that's the way we've always done it and
we don't know how to do anything else
this thing every single
synapse is and axon is connected to
maybe a thousand
or 10,000 other ones so it's very very
complicated way that these are all
connected together so in fact people
have come up with the first ideas things
that are called neural networks and
those are actually realized in actual
devices to be able to do things like
pattern recognition and you know what it
did they were able to actually recognize
patterns much faster than the way that
people would do it now we're still at
the very beginnings of understand how to
connect up those things with the neural
networks and the various types of rules
where the things are connected and how
things feed back so we still have a long
way to learn in that but at least
there's an existence proof that it works
differently and it works not works not
like the things on the left but a little
more like the things on the
right and so there's a whole big area of
electronics looking at oh maybe this and
they call a
biomorphic type of integration of
circuits
of architecture and of software we don't
understand the software over here that
is Windows or something like that and
you know how clunky that is and that
crashes every once in a
while well that crashes once in a while
too but in fact the interesting thing uh
is that that is not just
electrical it's actually very chemical
too so all the electronics and the
chemistry com in together in fact we
haven't been able to address that onto
electronic devices and in fact that's an
area of research I'm trying to get
into
yeah show the Curr State can it
do oh that's how many synapses it
has
yeah um no so what if you're ta
something
body ah yeah so in fact there's two
areas of of Interest here is can you use
and tap into the brain or the human body
to do things one of the interesting
things that people are thinking about
from tapping into the human body not the
brain just the body is to use the energy
generation cycle what called the ATP
cycle that we have in our system to
actually Power Electronics and some
people have actually demonstrated some
circuitry to be able to do that it's not
very good yet hopefully it's going to
get better than
that being able to use Electronics to
tap into this is just at its very
beginning so uh I think that's kind of
complicated in fact my area I want to
instead of tapping into a brain like
that of which 10 to the 14th I don't
know how to control that but in fact
there's this little worm called a seans
that's got about 300 synapses I think I
can tap into to that so I'm going to
start right there on understanding
simple systems to be able to then
generalize to that so are we going to be
able to tap into that and understand how
it's thinking well I think we're going
to someday but it's a long road
yeah do you foresee electronics and now
technology one day replacing chemistry
in U in addressing human disease and uh
repacing medicine
um so I'm standing in a chemistry
building with another chemistry
professor over
here they compliment each other so in
fact the electronics that you see there
is kind of a blend of of chemistry and
of electronics together so right now uh
the way that we do things like
quantitative analysis for chemistry we
have a lot of good sophisticated tools
of which this one of this guy is one of
the leaders
of but the electronics has only been
kind of the computers to run all that
stuff and over the last few years people
have started to get the electronics into
the sensing system to be able to
actually do that and in some
applications it's good some applications
it's bad so there's a blend of various
types of electronics that we can be able
to do I think you're going to see within
five years because in fact I'm uh
working with a company that's doing this
you're going to have something in your
hand to be be able to say whether or not
you have
malaria or whether or not you have uh
certain breast cancer uh marker in you
so you're going to see portable
Electronics I mean right now what is
what is wearable Electronics you know
it's a little accelerometer it tells you
how F you know how much you moved that's
all it
is but at some stage is actually going
to read your sweat and tell her tell you
whether or not that you should maybe go
in and see the
doctor um and uh for example here's a
great example is that there are some
people that have to take a certain
well-defined uh amount of medicine every
day or every week or something like that
to be able to stabilize their hormones
or certain proteins in their blood and
in fact the sad situation is most of
those people don't do it correctly and
they end up uh having a serious disease
diseases as a result for example there's
a chronic heart disease or you have to
take a daily dose of something to be
able to do that if you could actually
measure those things and now they have
actually have to run into the doctor's
office and get a blood test and that's
you know they get tired of that after a
while then eventually you'll be able to
do it yourself and be able to see that
everything is good it might be too much
information you know you might say um
don't eat that
steak but uh I think that the future of
where this is going
yeah well I mean what we could do is we
we don't have a knob that we can turn
there as far as okay I have a brain that
only thinks this much and that's
increase and stuff and when you cross
species there's a bunch of other things
however there is another plot that's
very important and that is this one
right
here uh that I skipped
over um because it had a lot of
information but here's the important
thing this is how fast things switch
what their power dissipation is and
these lines simply say all your things
are on the same amount of of energy so
lines like this are constant
energy over the years our Electronics
has gotten better and better and better
and better and this is pretty much the
limit of what we can do due to some
things and what happens is I go up this
and I go up this and I go up this and
the synapse is right
there so in fact that's what's motivated
me to do this is that synapses work very
slow I mean this only operates at a few
tens of
Hertz but it does it incredibly
efficiently so that's why I think the
biological computation which evolved on
low power uh is the important thing now
how has Evolution how is the if you take
things and increase 10 to the 15th or 10
to the 16th or 10 to the 17th synapses
does it compute better we don't know yet
um I think fundamental understanding
will realize if there are certain limits
to how big these biological computation
systems could be that's a great
interesting
question yeah one
lasted start so when are we going to see
the next big increase in computered
um when would when will we see the next
increase in computer speeds there are
two answers to that number one is my
answer which says that
never however with the caveat is that
people are looking at some of these
alternative computational type uh
devices and
structures and right now the research is
just very young very beginning a lot of
it isn't working very well but that's
why you do research if one of those
actually comes in and hits our home run
we might actually see that but in the
absence of that I don't think we're
going to see that is that clocking
speeds and the now how how have we
gotten out additional performance well
what's happened is finally the software
Engineers had to go back and say oh and
I got to get to work and make it more
efficient so what they're doing is and
here's an interesting thing is uh little
little story when I was growing up my my
dad would get absolutely furious at me
if I would walk out of the room and lean
the lights
on and says you know we a Rockell shut
off now a big computer chip like the one
I showed you right here you know the way
we design them is everything is always
on and Computing well in fact some of
the latest generations of computer chips
when you aren't actually doing the
computation they shut everything
off and then they run over they do this
computation and I got the answer for
that I'm going to run over here I'm
going to shut that off and turn this
back on again so it's actually shutting
the lights on and off in the room and
they've actually gotten better
performance out of it so clock speeds
haven't changed the number transistors
haven't changed they say change the
software on how things going so we're
going to start to see software
Innovations over the next few years to
be able to increase your performance but
the whole bottom line is it's eventually
going to do that
so that's why I say Electronics is going
to dramatically change within your
lifetime it's either going to slow down
and
saturate or there's going to be and
that's what I think is going to happen
there going to be some new tremendous
innovations that are going to happen and
that's the fun of
research
[Applause]
okay